Hey everyone, I'm Joe. I'm one of the
creators of Luminal. And so today in
this talk, I'm going to explain what it
is, how it works, and why we really
think that it's the future of ML
libraries. So the title of the talk is
radical simplific simplification through
search. And that really is the theme of
Luminal. We are far simpler than most
other ML libraries. And yet we are not
taking a hit on performance or
capability because we are using uh
compilers and more specifically search.
So deep learning fundamentally is very
simple. It's simple linear algebra. And
so basically all that really is is is
you know scalers, vectors, matrices and
tensors. And then a couple core ops, a
couple core operations. So we have
additions, multiplies, matt moles, some
elementwise ops in between and that's
that's mostly it. But if deep learning
is so simple, why aren't the libraries
simple? So the machine learning software
ecosystem is very very complicated. Um
PyTorch is one of the most famous
libraries out there. It has over 1,200
operations
uh and has over 15 different data types.
It runs on a ton of different kinds of
devices. Uh CPU, CUDA, AMD, TPUs, uh
some NPUs out there. And the problem
with all of this is that complexity does
not scale just by adding these together.
You don't have to have the number of
operations plus the number of data types
plus the number of uh supported devices.
It's actually multiplicative. So the
number the complexity scales with ops
times data types times number of
devices. And so once you raise any of
those you want to support a new op or a
new data type or a new device your
complex complexity starts exploding. So
what that what's happened to pietorch is
it's now over like 3 million lines of
code. Uh tensorflow is even much worse
than this. So it's extremely extremely
complicated pieces of software and this
hurts because there's a lot more bugs
obviously if you have a ton more code
but it's also just very hard for people
to ever extend or use or build anything
inside
of. So what we do is we take the
approach of looking top down at machine
learning and then saying fundamentally
what are the minimum amount of things we
need in order to make ML models run. So
deep learning again like I said is
linear algebra. Linear algebra boils
down to simple ops. So what if we just
built these very complicated models out
of like Lego blocks of very simple
operations. So what we do is we have uh
12 operations that were very very very
simple. Um and so we have x2 log 2 s and
reciprocal and square root. Those are
our unary operations. We have uh our
binary operations addition,
multiplication, modulo and less than.
And then we have our reductions. So we
have sum reduce and max reduce. And with
those just those operations, you can
support all of the big models out there.
All of the commercially relevant models
that everybody cares about. So you can
do language models, vision language
models, uh CNN's, RNN's, you can do um
uh diffusion models, all these other
very very popular models.
Is that really it? I mean, that's not a
lot of ops. Is that really all it takes
to uh to represent all of this? Well,
it's a lot of these other operations
that you would have expected to see on
the list are really just uh uh formable,
usable by combining different operations
on this list. So, subtraction is really
simple. It's just addition and
multiplication with a negative one.
Division is really simple because it's
just multiplication and a reciprocal on
B. Uh map moles are really simple if you
have the ability to manipulate the shape
metadata of your tensor. So you can
basically just do a broadcasted multiply
and then sum reduce it down and you get
the output of matmo. So you don't need a
matt mole op. Um, convolution is really
simple if you have the ability to do
pooling through uh shape trackers again
and then you do a maple like we just
discussed with the the convolution
kernel and you get the output of a
convolution. And so another thing we
realized when we were building this is
that all of these existing libraries are
built with dynamism at their core and
they were usually they were mostly built
uh you know 5 to 10 years ago when
dynamism was very important. So people
were experimenting with RNN's and LSTMs
and all these fancy models and they
needed a whole lot of hackability and
dynamism and they didn't so much care
about performance. Um so they you know
pietorrch is very very dynamic but
because of that it's a lot more complex.
So deep learning fundamentally isn't
dynamic. it was just there for
convenience. But the dynamism inherent
to models here is very very small and
very very bounded. So in a transformer
model the only real thing that is
dynamic is the KV cache length and the
actual sequence length. And aside from
that the entire model is static. Um and
so what we do is we specify these models
as directed as cyclic graphs of
operations. So right in front of us we
see a really simple example where we're
loading in a tensor, we're loading in a
weight and then we are elementwise
multiplying them together and then we
are sum reducing them. And right here
like we talked about this is a maple.
This is what a matrix multiply is. And
so right on screen this is all that a
single dense uh neural network layer is.
It's just your your your matrix
multiplying by a weight matrix. So on
the right hand side here we see a much
larger model and so these graphs you can
kind of see get quite a bit more comp
complex uh but they are capable of fully
specifying these
models. So the consequence of this is
that luminal is really really simple
despite it being able to actually
represent and run all of these different
models in the world. It's under 5,000
lines of code. Uh it's very easy to
understand. And our goal here is that we
are going to uh this whole library
really should be learnable in an
afternoon. So you should be able to sit
down and understand the core structure
and core concepts of it in you know a
couple hours here. So that doesn't
necessarily mean it's fast though. So
Llama 7B uh right out of the box runs uh
you know it takes about all day to
generate a single sentence. Super duper
slow. But the point isn't to run these
primitive graphs of operations here. The
point is to take these graphs and then
run them through some functions to
transform them into faster graphs. And
so we do that with compilers. So we
compile our way back to high
performance. So before we get to talk
about compilers here, I just want to
again highlight um what this
simplification gets us. A traditional
stack is you might be using something
like hugging face transformers. It's a
great library. It sits on top of
pietorch and xformers and uh you know
some other libraries that provide
optimized kernels. These libraries
inside them have a bunch of handwritten
kernels uh that try to be adaptable for
all these different use cases and then
those handwritten kernels may call
operations in coupnn or kublos which
then sit on top of cuda and so all of
this creates a very complex dependency
story. Anybody who's tried to install a
deep learning setup on a new machine
knows that this is a non-trivial thing.
uh a lot of the times it's you know
dependency hell that you're stuck in. Um
and it's just it's just you know having
very complex uh stacks means that once
there's a bug tracing that down through
a really complex stack is is a huge pain
as well. So generally we want to keep
our stack as simple and straightforward
as possible. Uh with Luminal we directly
emit CUDA code. We directly generate
CUDA code and so there really is nothing
between us and CUDA. It's just our
library, our graph, our compilers, and
CUDA right
beneath. So, like I said, Luminal is
slow by default, but you're never meant
to run any of these uh primitive op
graphs. So, you're supposed to we're
going to take these graphs and we're
going to feed them through compilers and
they're going to spit out much faster
graphs. So, how does that actually work?
I mean, we're not the first to think of
compilers here and we're not the first
to think of ML compilers. Why haven't
other ML compilers taken over the world?
Um, it's really because as your code
that you want to generate grows in
complexity, your compiler scales with
the the square or the cube of that
complexity. It scales really really fast
because your compiler needs to now emit
needs to generate that final code. And
so if you double the the complexity of
your kernels, your compiler might have
to 10x in complexity. So at some point
these compilers just become too complex
for people to write. Uh and so that
really has put a bottleneck on the
current ecosystem. It's put a bottleneck
on a lot of hardware startups with very
fancy uh hardware that you know they
they want to compile stuff down to. Um
and and it's actually getting worse. So
as we demand more and more out of our
hardware, the hardware we need to keep
and make simpler and simpler because
generally the simpler your hardware can
get uh the more uniform it can get and
the faster it can get. So as an example
of this CPUs are very very complex. They
try to predict what the programmer
wanted to do. um they try to make life
easier for the programmer, but as a
consequence, they're very complex pieces
of hardware and they don't run very fast
for operations that we care about. GPUs
are a lot simpler. GPUs require the
programmer to specify things ahead of
time, set things up, um explicitly use
certain memories, uh dispatch kernels,
and do certain communications
explicitly. And the GPU doesn't handle
that for you. It handles some things for
you like scheduling but uh the software
needs to do a lot more but as a
consequence the hardware is simpler and
it's a lot faster. You get much better
performance per watt. Uh TPUs are even
simpler. So the programmer has to handle
everything. The programmer has to
schedule things and has to uh explicitly
allocate and manage all this memory. Um
but the TPUs are very very simple. So
the TPUs are extremely fast, very good
performance per watt and we want to
basically keep walking down this path of
simpler, faster hardware and uh more
complex software. So what that means is
our our compiler needs to get more
complex. Uh we actually run into a very
typical traditional problem in uh CS
which is the VIW compiler problem. uh
VIW stands for very large instruction
width and a it's a very very standard
paradox where companies want to make
their hardware simple. So they want to
to basically have the compiler
statically schedule and set everything
up beforehand. But the problem is that
beyond a certain point compilers just
get way too complex and humans just
can't write those compilers anymore.
It's just too hard. So, how do we
actually get past that in Luma? Uh,
well, we actually turned to the same
solution that the Alph Go Alph Go guys
did when they were creating AlphaGo and
they wanted to crack the game of Go,
they said that they were not super
genius Go players, that Go was a very
tough problem. And instead of trying to
write like the perfect algorithm that
would be able to solve go in one shot
and always find the best
move, instead what they did is they were
they turned to search and they said,
"We're going to search through a whole
bunch of uh boards here of board
states." And so we're going to do this
like really fancy tree search and we're
going to use this guided neural network
to to go through it. Uh but the point is
that search ate the complexity of Go.
And so what we're doing is the exact
same thing. We are searching instead
through a instead of goboards, we are
searching through logically equivalent
GPU kernels. So this means that we don't
need to handw write out a whole bunch of
rules and then hope that they always
work to produce fast code. What we can
do is we can write a whole bunch of
simple rules to build this big search
space and then let the search go through
and find the fastest
kernels. So what does this actually look
like? Well, we take our graphs, uh, the
graphs that we were talking about
before, and we convert them into
expressions in this library called egg
log. Um, this library basically uses
egraphphs to represent these this search
space in a very memory efficient way.
And then it goes ahead and it does this
search through all of these equivalent
expressions, this equivalent
intermediate
representation. And we specify out, you
know, 20 or 25 different rewrite rules.
These rewrite rules are very, very
simple. All they do is make a small
alteration to a given GPU kernel. And we
know that the output is logically
equivalent. We don't know if it's
necessarily faster or slower, but we
know it's logically equivalent. So it
adds to our search space. And our search
space as we iteratively apply and apply
and apply these these simple rewrite
rules as many times as we can, we build
up a super super large uh search space.
And then what we do is we just go
through and we look through all of these
different equivalent kernels and we test
their run times and we see how fast they
are and then we choose the fastest one.
It's really that simple. And beyond a
certain point it becomes infeasible to
search uh to to profile the runtime of
every every possible kernel. And so we
start to use things like Monte Carlo
research to sort of prune down the
search space. But at the end of the day
uh it is fundamentally a search
problem. So what are these kinds of
optimizations that end up getting found
through this search space? Um kernel
fusion is a very popular one. Uh simply
you know you have operation A, operation
B. Operation B operates on the output of
operation A. In this example here we
have sign and then followed by X2. So x2
operates on the output of sign. So the
naive way is we go and we uh we do we
load the tensor from memory into the
compute unit. We do sign we write the
tensor back into global memory and then
we read the same stuff back into the
compute unit. Do x2 again and then we
write it back into memory. Uh but this
is really bad. In fact, data movement in
GPUs is usually like 99% of the energy
spent and the time spent. Very few very
small amounts of time and energy are
spent on actual compute. So instead of
doing all this roundtpping, what we can
do is we can just merge X and sign into
the same kernel, load the data in once
and then write the data back out once we
are we done. We're done. We have our
final results.
So what does this actually look like in
practice? Well, on the left we have an
unfused graph. It's a very, very sloppy,
naive graph where we're doing a whole
bunch of these different operations. And
then in between them, we always have to
write our result back to memory and then
read it back into the compute unit for
the next operation. And what our
compiler has done here on the right is
been able to merge all of them down into
one kernel. And like I said, how data
movement is 99% of uh runtime. The the
crazy thing is that this real complex
kernel on the right here actually
doesn't take much longer than any one of
these kernels on the left here. So this
whole kernel in a or this whole graph in
aggregate is far far faster than the
graph on the left in aggregate.
So one of the real big achievements that
we've had uh recently with our search
technique is we were able to find flash
attention. Flash attention is a very
very very complicated algorithm that uh
took about 5 years for the industry to
discover uh for for somebody in the
industry to discover. So uh Tree Dow
discovered it in uh 2022. Transformers
came out in 2017. And yet this is like a
really really important optimization on
our our R compiler now is able to find
this completely by itself. Uh so again
what do we do? We take in the naive
multi head attention graph. We run all
of these different simple rewrite rules.
We build out this huge search space. We
profile a bunch of these kernels and
find the fastest one. And the fastest
one in this case just happens to be
flash attention. And to our knowledge,
we're the only compiler in the world
that can do something like this. U and
it's because we're able to leverage
search. Again, this is an extremely
complex optimization here. It's it's not
at all obvious um to program into a
compiler. So, we did a little
announcement about this. Uh on the
right, you could see my announcement
tweet here. On the left, you can see uh
the generated flash attention kernel in
green here. And then in white we have
the intermediate representation. It
might be a little bit tough to see. Um
but yeah, this is the generated output
code. And so okay, once we have this
really fast uh kernels that are
generated out of this search
function, what do we do? Do we just
directly uh generate the CUDA code from
that and then run it? We could do that,
but there are a set of optimizations
that we know will never be harmful. We
don't know exactly how much they will
help, but we know they will always be
helpful. And so what we do is we run
these deterministic optimizations on the
output of our search process. And these
optimizations are things like buffer
reuse.
So obviously we want to minimize the
amount of memory uh we use. And so we
want to optimally reuse all of our
memory buffers. And because we have the
entire workload specified as this big
graph ahead of time, we can have our
compiler go in there and say like, okay,
uh, in this example right here, buffer
one is never being used at the exact
same time as buffer three. And so
anytime we once we need buffer three, we
know buffer one is done. It's not going
to be used again. And so what we can say
is, oh, buffer one and buffer three
should actually just be the same
buffers. And so we see in the bottom
here, that's exactly what we're doing.
we're just saying that these two are the
same exact memory buffer. So this is how
we can optimally uh uh reduce our memory
usage. Another way we can optimize our
final graph here is we issue the kernels
all at once. So in traditional uh
inference what you do is you have a CPU
dispatch a GPU kernel and then the GPU
runs that kernel. We wait, we wait for
it to finish. It goes back to the CPU.
the CPU then dispatches the next kernel.
That round trip to the CPU and then
waiting on the CPU to dispatch the next
kernel takes a lot of time. And so what
if we were to dispatch all of our
kernels ahead of time uh and then the
GPU would just run through them one by
one by one. So we do that in our
compiler as well. Uh and so we we build
this big queue. We could actually see
the difference on the left hand side
here. The launch time we actually have
to wait quite a while to launch. Whereas
here we can launch all of the kernels at
once and we save a whole bunch of
time. So Luminal was from day one always
an inference library. Uh it was never
really designed with training in mind.
But due to the extreme flexibility that
our graph representation gives us, we
were able to actually build an external
crate an external library that is an
autograd engine and it works uh directly
in luminal and it basically deres given
a forward graph it deres a backward
graph and then attaches that to it and
then we run our downstream compilers
which means we basically get training
for free. Uh so all of the compilers
that we have for inference, the search
process, all of that also works for
training. So it runs right on the the
backward pass as well. Um this is pretty
neat too that it was added as an
extension because to my knowledge, I
don't think any other ML library out
there is able to do this. Any any
library that uh supports training has to
have it as part of their core. uh
whereas we're able to add it in as an
external thing which means somebody else
can come in external contributors can
come in and just write their own
autograds or their own gradient charting
or their own really fancy training
setups. So that's sort of a brief
overview of where we are today, the
features we have today. Uh what's to
come? Well, we're really excited about
adding more hardware support in. So
right now we support CPU uh CUDA and
metal. Uh what we really want to do is
support AMD uh tentor torrent uh gro and
TPUs. Um because these are all like
really exciting hardwares out there. We
want to break the coupe ideally and uh
sort of democratize ML across all these
different hardware.
Um we want to do distributed inference
and training. So we want to do full 3D
distributed uh through data parallel
pipeline parallel tensor parallel um and
uh we want to do RL. So a common
bottleneck in RL is we want to basically
we run our model on the GPU but we run
our environment on the CPU. Uh and then
that back and forth is the huge
bottleneck. So if we can codify
environments, we've done this for very
simple environments, but we want to see
how complex we can go codify the
environment in the luminal graph and
that gets optimized with the rest of the
model through our our same compiler
flow. And so basically we run the
forward pass of the model and step the
environment all on the GPU. Um so this
is this is super exciting because I
think it could dramatically accelerate
uh reinforcement reinforcement learning
workflows. Um, our Dyson sphere
unfortunately is pending our Sequoia
fund raise. So, you know, reach out to
us if you have any info on that. Um, but
what we've really been working on
recently is the Luminal cloud. So, what
we've done because we were able to
represent these models as graphs. If
you're working on a model in Luminal,
you can do graph.export, get a file out,
upload that file to the cloud, and then
get a serverless inference endpoint. And
we handle everything else. So we handle
optimization, we handle batching and
queuing, we handle turning the, you
know, provisioning the machines. Um,
it's totally serverless. You only pay
for when your graph is actually
executing. So we think we can deliver
the simplest, fastest, uh, most
straightforward cloud experience out
there. Um, so yes, come join us. Uh,
there's the link to the uh link to the
the repo. We would love uh PRs. If you
have any ideas, uh, please join us. And
we're we're really pushing into
territory that's only been pro covered
by frameworks that are orders of
magnitude more complex here. So, it's
it's a really exciting time. Uh,
simplicity really allows us to do these
innovations far faster than frameworks
that have so much more overhead. Uh, so
it's super exciting. And then if you're
a startup or a company that has an
inference workload, uh, reach out. Um,
we're building again the simplest,
fastest ML cloud in the world. And so,
please reach out to me. I'm at joe
luminalai.com or you can just go to
luminalai.com. Um, we'd love to hear
what your workload is and if we could
help you out. Thanks, guys.